and it just so happened that we were
vibing with Steve so well and he kind of
fit that role of David even though he's
completely different but I think it was
just David was a talker and Steve talks
too we just didn't want another person
that didn't fing talk you know that's
fair so then like like for
example y talk smell
talk
[Music]
yeah welcome back to another uh highly
controversial episode of care for boys
is this OTR it may be it sounds like an
OTR it feels like an OTR what a cool
answer but if we don't make it to the
length of an OTR then it's not an oh wow
today we're finally going to settle once
and for all who's been here longer
Anthony or Steve me no question about it
why because I put in the hours the man
work what does that mean but like who
started here that means he didn't have a
side job video after you do you know
Anthony longer this I had a I had a side
job I was writing movies Duncan all over
Hollywood movies with Kevin Hart making
movies with Josh making movies with
whoever else was in that movie as well
he's a plan longer hours or
longer first of all let's let's sort
this out and organize it who did you
meet first yeah that's a good question
and that doesn't
matter we met Anthony first irrelevant
to the when in the horse race it's a
clear winner so far uh I want day we met
maybe
2009 wait we met have we met before tick
tick have we met before that or was that
when we actually met I think that's when
we met tic tick we met met at the TIC
tick tour Australia and then after that
we would sporadically see each other
when we did when we were booked for the
same shows I remember Stanford with you
I remember just like the poster hang in
the bathroom there's a poster there I
saw that yeah shout out to shout outs to
Andrew
Bina when I'm in the bathroom
and there would be sprinkle of moments
where back here by the way where where
Anthony would be in some of our sketches
back in the day I remember that so why
doesn't that matter before JK news Okay
so he took like I don't know seven years
off um it's nice that you guys shook
hands one
time I was here in the muck crawling
Army crawling fighting the [__] all I
know is I'm not insecure about it cuz
fighting the [__] Wars here dude we
went to battle we fought we saw
things where were you where were you
probably opening car dealerships in
Dubai that's actually a nice place that
sounds kind of sick actually better than
Indonesia it's better than do you agree
was Steve here during the trenches and
all yeah for sure yeah yeah yeah War
Steve I want to say what was it like
trench trench is a conceptual concept
right I mean before they even got all
the money and open that giant ass office
I was WR he was there at the giant
office yeah at the office I was there
too that's where I met Nikki before you
I was filming at the office with Nikki
all
right I put in a good word for you with
Nikki wait so during the big office when
when Steve was there during the big
office you never came to the big one I
did oh said no he said no Anthony never
really worked on like you guys were busy
building kindas at the time but he would
like feature on JK news or like
collaborate I remember that yeah if you
asked me back then do you would I ever
think that he would be here I'll be like
no not like that no he's too big but
then when we're talking about who's been
here longer are we saying here as in
here as in JK news here I don't know
what they're arguing about we're not
arguing I'm just here trying to make
sure the facts are good he just needs
more wins because he's I'm a JK
historian he's insecure I'm not in
there's nothing to be insecure about
we've known Anthony
longer I think we've known Anthony
longer but I think Steve's put on put in
longer hours thank you seriously I
needed that thank you you know what the
best part about is though considering he
only comes here once a month now my
catchup Ste oh you're going to catch up
you're going to cat up it's not possible
and I'm okay with that I like a good
Underdog Story you know what I mean a
good Underdog Story you're not the
underdog I feel like we've known and
worked with Nikki for a good year or two
before we even met Steve yeah oh you
guys met you guys were working with
Nikki like 2015 and 2014 and I met you
guys in 2015 2016 w we met you at the
Rose that's only 5 years after me and
that's where you met Nikki is through JK
what's that you met Nikki through JK no
[__] no I met Nikki way earlier than
that can't say like that no no no they
made they met at the station I was
already taking her doggy style by the
time she was here at at the
station doggy style at the station with
Shay Carl yeah and Ray William Johnson
these jokes are only funny cuz Nikki so
sweet she doesn't deserve it yeah if she
did these wouldn't be fun no no all
right so it sounds like we're getting
closer to it okay he's put in more hours
you bet Anthony first though see I never
argued that I put in more hours uhhuh
all I know is that Steve hates it when
we talk about the Glorious Wolverine
video that we all did together cuz he
wasn't a part of that I'm just jealous
wait do you have a special affinity for
this Wolverine video like is it a symbol
that was a fun one that was really fun
actually that's when w it was just a
True Legacy moment of JK news history
making a t-shirt it was so good and so
fun why where's the T-shirt where's the
t-shirt that was my question it's worth
making merch that's all I'm saying by
the way you're bit steing all I'm saying
you're Ste and you know it hey have some
pizza you don't even know the inside
joke you don't even know have some pizza
you know
it bit stealer you don't even know y you
don't even know these things he do do
you feel like Anthony's presence in the
early days of JK films played a role in
the sustainability of JK news in [__] no
no they were way bigger than didn't you
do gay stuff too every every single time
we had them Bart loved booking them just
him and Lauren specifically to do gay
gay did you guys ever make Steve do gay
stuff no cuz I didn't even write gay
stuff they just started doing gay stuff
Steve's naturally good I I'm I'm just
riding to Friendly guys and then they
would start like Lawrence would Mount
his legs over Anthony's shoulders this
way for no reason art is organic and
natural oh so the treatment didn't
originally say by the way this is also
like I'm like what is JK films so I walk
into a film Bobby Le Jack himself off on
the [__] couch oh you saw that too
yeah I was lowy traumatized yeah wait
for real literal what you saw so we had
a scene of Bobby dud I'm sorry I missed
that now we have a scene brok I'm broken
up about it yeah there's a scene that we
wrote for Bobby I forgot what what video
this was for but he just needs to
pantomim so he could have just gone like
this okay and then we we called action
and he goes he literally spits in his
hand like for reals he starts going o
ooh ooh ooh he starts touching himself
for reals it's like method acting
everyone's in like on set going like he
doesn't have to do this and it's
supposed to be like a 10-second shot he
goes for like 5 minutes and then right
after he goes don't [__] make me do
that
again none of us made you do that bro
and this is like Bart's old house right
this was Casey's house I remember that I
remember that what the [__] yeah that
was funny I remember you remember that
yeah
that was awesome all I'm saying is when
you ask who was here longer I think it's
clear and that's okay you were here for
longer hours I get it you were in the
trenches was he here for more difficult
hours Let's more difficult hours
definitely yeah I was here for great
glorious Legacy hours they're different
of course they're categorized this
different ways remember JK news at the
end of the day was built off of the hard
Sweat Equity of JK films okay okay so
those of us that went in those trenches
all right none of us see Glory we're
just proud to be a part of the Legacy
even the Free Labor of JK films yeah got
it so that's it I'm I'm just a humble
servant to that era okay all credit to
you the trenches of JK news in 2015 5
years after me later stuff cool feel
like you're mocking me and I don't like
if you had to Value the hours who who
worked more high value hours stop saying
hours I see you're playing died here
you're saying hours cuz it's always
clear that he had more hours I think
that benefits my case thank you well per
hour the value of it per hour even if
you did less they could be higher valued
you both kind of came in at perfect time
cuz his is foundational right because uh
David David wanted to go off and abandon
us and and it just so happened that we
were vibing with Steve so well and he
kind of fit that role of David
completely different but I think it was
just d David was a talker and Steve
talks too we just didn't want another
person that didn't [__] talk you know
that's fair so then like like for
example y talk no talkers yeah non
talkers or if they talk they talked
about stupid [__] and you're just like
why like for example what like people
that you don't see anymore have you ever
talked about stupid [__] only with you
no let us know in the comments that's
let us know in the comments you let us
know in the comments the com and I mean
you came in you came in when we needed
more hosts cuz we didn't have one Steve
was struggling at that time by himself
right yeah thing wa is that true did
Anthony start hosting to help Steve no
we we started hosting to help the show
because we ran out of hosts oh cuz they
fired all the host did I want to help
Steve yeah I did I did you know did I
ever need to take official credit with
the cameras rolling with the red lights
on no I just did it cuz cuz I was I
wanted to help my buddy but also it was
like why I was just like I I didn't
think that Anthony would like want to be
here like that much and that long cuz I
was like oh this is cool we always have
him on and then I was surprised that he
actually wanted to host I was like
that's [__] sick yeah stay on keep
stay and was that was that not a very
unique trench at that time yep because
the funny thing is the day the
announcement video came out of you going
I'm
remember that [__] day it was the
beaches of Normandy dude that thank you
for Ping up my case so no no no honestly
no honestly and just all jokes aside
here mad props to you for that cuz that
was brutal cuz on that was a slaughter
house on the same day yeah on the same
day that that that video comes out a
video of why I left [__] JK comes out
right oh that was the same day the whole
comment
they don't even give a [__] about anthy
they don't give a [__] about let me add
drama it's Anthony's first day hosting
it's it's an announcement video of we
have Anthony now as a fullon host
welcome to the team this other thing is
happening and props to him cuz he showed
up the next day too and like that's hard
like when you're getting the [__]
[__] kicked out of you and stuff and it
really wasn't about you but like but
they completely overshadowed whatever
like his awesome news the best part of
this is me being like a very excited and
proud little boy being like Nina look
this is my first video that I hosted and
then this is and I'm looking at the
comments and I'm like oh [__] what is
this the audience does love you though
they do the actual audience loves you
that was just like it would be nice if
the group did too so well that's not
good not everything could happen from
the audience point of view who do you
think they think has been here longer
from the audience point of view put it
in the comments it depends on how OG the
fan is cuz if the fan is like super OG
from the sketch days then probably
Anthony they think Anthony has because
cuz Anthony's in the OG category of JK I
was never in the sketch days Steve's not
in the OG category well even back then
Anthony will mid but if they're like die
hard JK news then probably Steve Steve
has way more
presence he's been way more involved JK
party like big office days JK party JK
news rer and I've always respected that
Steve
Anthony you know I love you [__]
you can we do a zoom in we're going to
pull that frame just crop it right in I
love this bit though I'll never get over
this bit what bit I thought we were
serious no the bit about how Anthony's
[Music]
gay